First, the problem.
Here's a simple website containing a
live stream of insightful gibberish from
multiple users.
It's a pattern you have seen on
multiple social networking sites.
And we're calling it, Witter.
Just in case lawyers are watching.
I've added it to my home screen so it
looks like a native app I might get from
the Play Store, except it still
has all the benefits of the web.
We call this a progressive app,
or we would if it weren't for
one little problem.
If I open it when I don't have
an internet connection, I get this.
This is a problem, but
not our biggest problem.
This is.
I call it Lie-Fi.
Let's enjoy the fruits of Lie-Fi for
a moment, shall we?
This is it, just
this forever and ever.
You're in connection limbo.
You could just put your phone in your
pocket and get on with something else.
But you keep waiting because
it might suddenly load.
Maybe within the next five seconds.
No, you should probably give up now.
But you know in your heart that
one second after you give up,
that would be the moment it would
have worked if only you'd waited.
So you wait, and wait.
This situation can be caused by a phone
barely holding on to a connection.
But sometimes your phone thinks it's
acing it in the connection department,
but nothing is getting through.
The problem is further down the line.
Somewhere between you and the server,
where the app and data lives.
There's a lot in between your phone and
the server.
Your phone sends the request to
the Wi-Fi router or cell tower.
Then onto the ISP, through
intermediate proxies and potentially,
across to the other side of the world.
And eventually, the request
reaches the destination server.
But that's only half the journey,
because the server responds.
And that response needs to go all
the way back across the world through
proxies, through ISPs, over the air and
land safe and sound on your phone.
But if something along the way, fails.
The whole thing fails.
If something along the way run slowly,
then the whole thing run slow and
there in lies lie-fi.
Maybe you have bad signal or maybe you
have perfect signal but the router or
tower you're connected to is overloaded.
For example, a crowded stadium or
a train station that's just
been hit by major delays.
Everyone's on their phone trying
to find another way home,
and the cell tower can't cope
when people need it most.
Or maybe there's a faulty or busy proxy.
Maybe the destination server is busy or
has a bug.
Loads of stuff can go wrong and we can't
predict any of this ahead of time.
The only way to know if we can get
a response is to send a request and
see what happens.
And that can take
a gruelingly long time and
the worst thing we can leave
the user with is nothing.
Let's do better.